ballmer namens luca herzlich willkommen
hier heute meine damen und herren liebe
zuschauer zuletzt infolge movistar
planet in den letzten wochen habe ich ja
so gut wie jede woche ein video hier in
movistar planet hochgeladen ich habe mir
ein account gemacht namens elefanten
aber das war ein junger und jetzt vor
einigen folgen habe ich mir noch einen
account gemacht namens in die aces das
ist sie hier und sie seien mädchen und
in der letzten folge habe ich euch
gefragt hey auf was habt ihr denn bock
was soll ich in der letzten folge so
machen und das einzige was aber
tausendfach geschrieben wurde war luca
bitte mal zehn minuten folge und daher
sieht es ja auch schon hier an der zeit
des videos das video geht auf jeden fall
über zehn minuten eine mir habe so eine
kleine xxl folglich doppelt so lang
gegen wie die pizza party leider ordnung
ich gehe aber mal kurz auf mein profil
weil ich glaube dass man dann hier
irgendwo genau da kann man auf geschenke
klicken und eventuell haben uns ja leute
irgendwie geld geschenkt sie danke für
das eichhörnchen
ja sage ich doch danke für das reh ich
kann hier einfach mal auftragen klicken
jetzt hab echt highscore fashion wieder
vielleicht hat mir ja irgendeiner geld
gesendet das heißt damit die keramik bei
jeder diese beschissene maske ja
wahnsinn sind die alta das ist richtig
fashion house es wäre echt mega geil
wenn irgendwo geld drin wäre damit ich
mir was kaufen kann um in diesem pitts
allerdings zu gehen
die schickt mir was ist das denn alter
merry christmas weidinger das video hier
heute geht auf jeden fall über zehn
minuten weil ihr euch das ja gewünscht
hat weil es hier heute so mehr oder
weniger die letzte folge ist ganz viele
von euch mainz war hey das projekt soll
weitergehen ich werde gerade angerufen
es hört sich halt dumm an aber ich kann
mittlerweile dieses spiel nicht mehr
richtig spielen weil es total am ruckeln
ist jetzt extrem seine version
heruntergeladen
wo ich sage ich mal ja so ein bisschen
mehr stabil habe er danke für diese
sachen max eine version jetzt runter
geladen
die halt ein bisschen stabiler läuft und
so weiter und so fort r schickt mir
keiner in die geld ja danke für deine
haare bruder ich guck mal hier bei
geschenken
da habe ich gar keine mir nicht eben
keiner einfach geld senden welser
kingsley tarasow so hier kommt so
einiges an staat level 11 ja auch noch
genau wie man bei level 12 bitte da
silva level 13 mitte den rockwell m14
mitte die kassette genau hier noch die
schuhe wälder will 560 nämlich dass hier
und sagt ich habe immer noch null euro
soll ich denn dann jetzt in diesem cup
thriller raum rein kommen aber egal gut
würde ich sagen wir gehen mal wieder ins
café dauert war mir auch ein bisschen
lieber als diese ganzen special kleiner
ordnungs räumen was ich gerade sagen
wollte ich kann das spiel hat wirklich
mehr richtig spielen weil überall
erkennen leute sind die asic und
elefanten a-liga die sind fame bis zum
mond aber auf jeden fall gesagt für die
heutige folge versuche ich mir hier
nochmal irgendwie boy zu klären mit sind
die asic und dann werde ich auch gleich
noch mal bei elefanten einloggen und
dass wir uns dort noch mal ein paar
nachrichten durchlesen das habt ihr euch
nämlich auch gewünscht also ich frage
jetzt erstmal ganz casual hier in dem
café hallo ich bin's cindy hat jemand
lust auf spinat essen standard smalltalk
beginn
okay sie hat uns auf jeden fall
geantwortet aber schauen wir uns mal ihr
profil ab ließ wl lehrern macht lux
okay da komm lass bisschen spinat
mampfen gehen bruder mit der liga
spielten hessen gehen und dann verlässt
er war das café aber gut hingeschaut zum
kaffee auch keiner mehr so richtig zu
antworten haben das heißt ich jetzt mal
ins einkaufszentrum hier ist alles
schwarz gemacht
strand hier ist auch alles schwarz
skatepark ist herum ist alles schwarz
also ich habe jetzt die ganze noch mal
neu gestartet das heißt jetzt wieder
hier auf chat einkaufszentrum es ist
hier so ist das denn alles schwarz hier
sogar das café ist mittlerweile schwarz
ich würde sagen dann gehen wir jetzt mal
in elefanten us account so freunde ich
habe mich jetzt mal in den account von
elefanten gerade eingeloggt und was
nicht da ist alles in ordnung wir machen
uns sorgen über die sachen die du auf
deinem profil gepostet hast es kann
daher sein dass wir inhalte von dir
gelöscht haben
die anderen usern erschrecken könnte
wirklich was könnten das sein hier
stinkt aller kassen nach dampfend im
parka solltest du diese inhalte verfasst
haben raten wir dringend über diese mit
deinen eltern deinem formen oder einem
erwachsenen deines vertrauens zu
sprechen also erst mal ganz ehrlich ich
habe also klar ich hab ein bisschen
schwachsinn immer mal gelabert aber ich
habe jetzt nicht irgendwie leute krass
beleidigt oder ja schon zwischendurch
ein bisschen licht darf tanzen wie ich
will das schöne an dem von elefanten
aber ist halt dass er halt wirklich 1600
euro hat du bist kein vip mehr aber gut
ok klicken die kacke immer weg gehen
jetzt mal direkt in den chat rein und
ich würde sagen wir schauen ob die ganze
kacke jetzt hier funktioniert also
kaffee geht auf jeden fall elefant navi
immer hübschen sonstwas model unterwegs
das café es auf jeden fall übertrieben
voll das heißt ich begrüße die leute
jetzt erstmal ein bit ich bin single hat
jemand lust auf tee trinken die real-
oder msp msp alter was denkst du denn du
plätze also dass ich jedes mal eine
verwarnung bekomme von wegen ich mit
leute beleidigen völlig unerhört was
habt ihr alter noch nie nehmen richtig
hübschen typ gesehen also sorry das kann
nicht wahr sein ihres cafés wir wieder
viel zu blöd er mich immer direkt weiter
an strand hier mit elefanten hab ich
meine frau hat zwar einen freundinnen
movistar plänen aber man kann ja
nie genug haben daumen hoch und bin zwar
in beziehung aber suchen die zweite
freundin lg man muss jetzt sicher direkt
drum herum reden ja okay ich suche schon
ein mädchen der gab ja aber ich brauche
jetzt gar nicht gelang umreißen bereich
reden nämlich bin einmal direkt raus
gegangen mit der wahrheit denn ich bin
ja in einer beziehung mit melinda 2009
10 aber hier sind ja noch drei weitere
plätze frei also vier freundinnen können
man schon mal machen will jemand mit mir
zusammen sein wg bruder ich will hier
eine freundin suchen und ich mit dir
eine wohngemeinschaft ziehen der echte
1871 also keine ahnung was das für ein
typ sm 3 jana schreibt du leider kein
rauch na ja na bitte zügelte ein
mundwerk du kleine heuschrecke wirklich
nicht mehr alles hier gefallen lassen
mit elefanten die leute beleidigen den
am laufenden band und ich bin ja schon
freudig die ganze zeit danke
gleichzeitig bin aber wenigstens einen
hübschen heuschrecken keine ahnung was
sie sagt der echte 1871 da die ganze
zeit von mir will einmal aber wir warten
jetzt mal eben die antwort von der
marine ab und dann würde ich sagen
bewegen wir uns mal die nachrichten weil
die wolltet ihr auch alle mal sehen
machst du and video ja darauf brauche
ich glaube ich gar nicht mehr eingehen
daher würde ich sagen verlassen wir
jetzt mal hier den strand und gehen mal
hier in meine nachrichten
da wir zwar nur 25 angezeigt ich habe
aber wirklich also das sind wirklich
oder angeben zu wollen in movistar pläne
bin ich schon echt vermögen also meine
letzte nachricht ich hier bekommen wir
vor einer minute ist du bist nicht der
echte luca oder weil der mal ein mädchen
war
was wie lena hat mir geschrieben hallo
die selber hat mir in geschenke schickt
die wie kann ich das denn jetzt
aufmachen
david hat mir auch einige geschenke
geschickt auf jeden fall im cubix gehört
hl geschrieben türkischer bei 14 12 auch
ein fach eingeschrieben schneeflocke hat
haye luca geschrieben elefanten warum
hast du so einen namen er ich bin dein
größter fan
du bist der beste halli hallo anna ich
wollte sagen dass nach vergammelt das
stinkt ganz normale nachrichten die ich
halte bekomme ich würde allerdings
wirklich gern aber zum abschluss in
diesem pizza party raum rein nämlich
das brauche ich also ab jetzt hier in
pizza party rhein wo jeden fall nach
also das hier ist dieser neue special
monster pizza party raum heißt ja ich
begrüße die leute einfach mal mit ich
bin die hotelgäste pixar im rufen hier
sind vor allem nur so high fashion leute
am start ich mein guckt euch mal hier
das outfit von diesem alex anja will man
eine antworten ist euch die sprache
vergangen weil ich so heiß bin nein nie
luca und das meine ich halt ein bisschen
er mit mobistar planet und warum das
hier auch jetzt vorerst erstmal die
letzte folge ist ein vielleicht laden
zwei drei wochen neuen part hoch wo ich
dann halt mir nochmal neuen account
mache und blabla aber ich kann halt
nicht mehr die lustigen sachen die ich
in den ersten folgen gemacht habe so
leute verarschen und so weiter und so
fort kann ich nicht mehr machen weil
alle leute in novi sad erinnert gefühlt
mittlerweile in fand nach erkennen und
wissen dass das ich bin ich möchte mich
auf jeden fall nochmal unfassbar krass
bei euch bedanken für den support unter
den ganzen videos hier mit elefanten und
mit sind die ace
wir haben auch so viele sachen noch gar
nicht gemacht wir waren bisher immer nur
im chat bereiche zum beispiel shopping
okay kann man jetzt glaube ich nur
sachen einkaufen movie town gibt es noch
das ist da kann man selber einen film
erstellen und so weiter und so fort dann
gibt es auch noch spiele dann gibt es ja
auch noch eine haustiere bereich der
kanzel hier zum zu gehen und so weiter
und so fort also ich glaube das spiel
hat noch ganz ganz viele sachen die ich
alle bisher noch gar nicht so richtig
wahrgenommen habe geschenke gibt's ja
irgendwas man kann dennoch ins forum
gehen da werden irgendwie neue sachen
angezeigt hier youtube diese funktion
ist noch nicht verfügbar da wird dann
wahrscheinlich demnächst mal ein kanal
oder auch verlinkt also man kann ja auf
jeden fall enorm viele sachen machen die
ich alle noch gar nicht ausprobiert habe
also wenn ihr unbedingt wollte dass
dieses projekt movistar pläne mit luca
weiter geht dann gibt auf jeden fall dem
video mal einen daumen hoch schreibt
wenn man in die kommentare
was sich dann eventuell machen soll ich
wollte nur sagen die nächsten 12 drei
wochen kommt jetzt erst mal kein video
mehr und das ist jetzt zuerst mal so das
ende von cindy asic und elefanten wenn
ihr allerdings wollt wie bereits gesagt
dass es weitergeht lässt die daumen hoch
da schreibt und in die kommentare
abonniert main kanal falls sie das dann
nicht verpassen wollte ist es kostenlos
und nochmal danke für euren riesigen
support die letzten wochen bei diesem
projekt hier und vielleicht können wir
noch ein bisschen weiterspielen habe
euch lieb
[Musik]